house democrats are promising to impeach
president trump
even though he has about i don't know 15
seconds left in office
they want to impeach the guy uh house
republican leader kevin mccarthy is
pushing back against this
suggesting maybe they censure president
trump instead i have a different idea
altogether
i think that the republican-controlled
senate should
censure or better yet expel kamala
harris
we will make the case i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from old schooled
who says you can't censor a dictator
the ones doing the censoring are the
dictators
thank you that is a very good point
everyone is calling trump
a fascist dictator not everyone everyone
on cnn
not everyone generally but you know the
left is calling
trump a dictator he's an authoritarian
a dictator right uh related to the word
diction dictionary right these sort of
things that you
can say and you can govern through your
speech trump can't even send a tweet
right now
much less is he a dictator and who is
controlling
the words of the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
hipster rasputin over in silicon valley
jack dorsey uh mark zuckerberg
who else who else is controlling it
doesn't sound like a dictator to me it's
these guys who control
the internet and sometimes who are good
at collecting a lot of data if you want
to make sure that your data
are not exposed and collected all the
time you got to check out expressvpn
let's talk about censorship on social
media sites and what you can do about it
the left wants to silence
and remove any voices that they don't
agree with twitter was supposed to be an
open platform
remember that well i would prefer if
their content moderators would stop
acting like the op-ed section of the new
york times instead of letting social
media sites revoke your right to free
speech
how about revoking their right to your
data
now you could just deactivate all your
social media accounts but that would
just be giving the left
exactly what they wanted in the first
place instead i prefer
expressvpn i know that you're always
thinking they're they're not going to
come after my data it doesn't matter
they don't want to
get my stuff they don't want to see what
i'm doing they do they do it's it's all
open folks
it's finally time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy at expressvpn.com
michael by visiting my special link you
will get an extra three months of
express vpn service
for free that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael expressvpn.com michael
to protect your data today go do it you
know how much i love expressvpn you know
that i love protecting
my online privacy i'm sure you do as
well go check it out
i'll get to the kamala of it all in a
second because
this is both i think something
worthwhile for senate republicans but i
think it's also
an attitude shift that republicans
generally need to understand
but first i i actually want to take
seriously
the democrats contention that donald
trump should be
impeached in his last 10 days or so
in office president trump they want to
impeach because he led an
insurrection on the government at
capitol hill
and he urged his mob to go become
violent
and invade the capital and scare off all
the legislators
and this is unacceptable it's a threat
to the republic
and therefore we've got to impeach him
that's the charge now what are the facts
president trump
called his supporters to dc for a big
rally he went out and addressed that
rally
he told people to be strong and he even
told them
or i guess described how they were
inevitably going to
march to capitol hill and therefore it's
an open and shut case right well let's
let's listen to what president trump
actually said we're going to walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show
strength and you have to be strong
[Applause]
we have come to demand that congress
do the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
today we will see whether republicans
stand strong
for integrity of our elections
but whether or not they stand strong for
our country
okay now you've probably heard the first
part of that
clip before you might not have heard the
second part where president trump
explicitly says
you're gonna go there and peacefully and
patriotically
make your voices heard
doesn't sound to me like he's inciting
an insurrection sounds like quite the
opposite right he's explicitly saying do
not be violent be peaceful
now you might say look he sent a mob of
extremely angry people over to the
capitol
and said be tough you got to be tough
you can't be weak
so therefore i don't know we got to
censure the president i actually
i understand the argument of house
republicans who want to censure the
president
probably wouldn't vote for it but i i at
least understand that argument
i don't see the argument for impeachment
he didn't do the thing that they are
saying that he did
and you can play the tape and listen to
it not that evidence is going to matter
all that much in an impeachment trial
which certainly an impeachment trial of
a president who is days away from
leaving office
is purely political there's no legal
basis for it at all
so this is basically where republicans
and conservatives
are fighting the issue right now should
we impeach trump
should we censure trump should we do
nothing at all what are they going to do
to us right it's all very defensive
i'd like to propose an alternative i
think that the
the democratic controlled house is going
to try to impeach trump
i think that the republican-controlled
senate should censure or better yet
expel
kamala harris last i checked kamala
harris is still a senator right
and will remain so until she becomes
vice president
so and i guess even if she weren't the
senate could still pass a resolution to
censure her
so why won't they do that kamala harris
did did not merely encourage
the peaceful protesters at the black
lives matter
riots all over the summer kamala harris
posted a fundraising link
for the rioters in minnesota who were
arrested
to bail them out of jail that's not
saying go over there and peacefully
protest
that's saying we are going to subsidize
your violent actions
we played a little bit of this briefly
yesterday on the show kamala harris went
on the colbert show and said
these rioters they ain't going to give
it up
i know that there are protests still
happening in major cities across the
united states i'm just not seeing the
reporting on it that i
that i had that's right for the first
few weeks um but they're not
they're not gonna stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you
they're not gonna stop and and everyone
beware
because they're not gonna stop it is
gonna they're not gonna stop before
election day in november and they're not
gonna stop after election day
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels that this
isn't they're not going to let up and
they should not and we should not
they're not going to let up and and they
should not and we should not now you
might say michael
kamal is not talking about the rioters
kamala's talking about the mostly
peaceful protesters
i'm not so sure of that because there
was a lot more
violence a lot more widespread violence
during the blm riots than anything that
happened at the capitol bad as it was
but but moreover if you're going to say
that about kamala harris certainly have
to say that about trump if you're going
to say blm was mostly peaceful
surely you have to say that the capitol
hill was mostly peaceful
donald trump went out there and said you
have to do this peacefully
kamala harris didn't say anything like
that not in that clip and certainly not
in the fundraising link the fundraising
link
subsidizes the violence anything they're
going to accuse trump of
anything they're going to bring up in
this impeachment trial kamala harris is
far more guilty of the house control or
the democrats control the house rather
republicans control the senate how come
it's only ever house
democrats who are aggressing how come
it's only ever the left
who are doing anything why is the right
always on defense why won't mitch
mcconnell go out there
and at the very least send your kamala
harris
and better yet expel her if they're
going to try to impeach trump expel
kamala harris
i don't think that what what trump did
giving a rally say
say go be peaceful i don't think that's
an impeachable offense
a little questionable to send a mob down
to capitol hill but certain
nothing nothing that he did is
impeachable
so so if you're going to impeach the guy
for that surely
surely we have to apply even something
close to the same standard
to the democrats who did far worse but
that's not going to happen mitch
mcconnell's almost certainly not going
to do it i mean call your congressman
call your senator rather try to make it
happen but
but it almost certainly will not because
of this systemic problem on the right
which is that we play defense and we
roll over
and the left aggresses and aggresses and
aggresses
the la all we're talking about here is
following legal procedures
even that the right is not willing to do
kamala harris says yeah it's not gonna
stop it won't stop
bail out the criminals we're gonna have
a great time
no consequences whatsoever might not
even need to wait by the way for these
impeachment proceedings
if any of you were checking the state
department website yesterday
i know it's not not exactly my home page
i don't go there all the time but if you
did check the state department website
yesterday
if you checked under president trump's
heading you would have read
donald j trump's term ended on january
11
2021 at 7 49 p.m
i assume eastern time now this went up
before 7 49 eastern time
the vice president's biography was
edited to say michael r pence
his term ended on january 11 2021
at 7 44 eastern time
the time stamp on the president's page
changed multiple times
then it was removed in the late
afternoon and replaced with a 404
reading that said sorry
this site is currently experiencing
technical difficulties
when a lot of us saw that with given all
the shenanigans that have gone on in
this entire presidency
we thought gosh does the state
department know something we don't know
is there is this impeachment thing
really happening or worse i mean what
what is going on here
then it was floated it was being
reported i guess baselessly
that this was a hack now the story that
we're being told by the state department
is it was not a hack it was a
disgruntled employee
there's no way to hack into the very
highly secure
state department website then it later
came out that the infrastructure for the
state department website is
wordpress is you know the
like the blogging platform that a lot of
a lot of websites use it's very very
good software
but uh you think i figured the state
department would have something super
duper advanced
not like the blog that i had when i was
15.
i bring this up one it was a very
strange thing they're saying it's a
disgruntled employee there are plenty of
leftists at the state department so i
wouldn't be surprised at all
but i bring it up actually for a sort of
tangential point which is
we're we're all very taken with these
kind of conspiracy ideas these days
the left ran with it for four years on
russia and whatever ukraine all this
nonsense
but the right enjoys conspiracies too we
all want to be part of the secret
knowledge the state department website
runs on a very basic popular
web service to me that dispels a lot of
conspiracies
because we think that it's all these
super geniuses
that are working in all these you know
agencies of the government
it's mostly incompetent bureaucrats
there are bad dudes too who do lots of
bad things and abuse their power i'm
thinking of guys like andy mccabe peter
strzok there is a lot of bad stuff i'm
not i'm not downplaying that at all
but i guess it's a sort of consolation
how incompetent
much of this bureaucracy is it does
quash a lot of these
a lot of these theories a lot of these a
lot of these guys can't uh
can't do very much they don't even avail
themselves of the tools
at their disposal i would recommend
however that you avail yourself of tools
at your
uh at your disposal with hymns if you
care about
men's wellness for hymns.com is all
about
men's wellness need help with ed hair
loss or have a cold are you interested
in mental health or covid 19 home tests
kim's is here for you through hymns you
can get the prescription medication that
treats ed
real science real solutions kim's makes
it easy
hims connects you with a licensed
medical professional online who can
prescribe
fda-approved prescription medication to
treat ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that's expensive little pill
but without the expensive price tag no
more searching online for answers to
questions about eb or sexual wellness
just
go to your hems account and ask a
medical professional you can trust
if there is a simple solution available
to a problem that a lot of people face
maybe you should avail yourself of that
solution try hymns today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hymns dot com
slash michael for your free visit that
is for hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot hims.com
michael
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate see website for full details
and safety information
remember that is for hims.com michael go
check out hymns
very good stuff
very incompetent people in the
government
one of the great ways to dispel these
conspiracy theories could
do you think there could be some super
arch conspiracy in
the state of new york i don't think so
do you know why not because they
wouldn't want to they're
very very corrupt people generally
speaking
especially in the democratic party up in
up in albany and new york
i just don't think they're competent
enough andrew cuomo gave his state of
the state
yesterday some people have called him
andrew kovid
that's very mean but pretty pretty true
with andrew cuomo he has now
handled the virus worse than any
governor in the country he has kept the
state closed he sent six people into
nursing homes
he's wasted the vaccine he didn't
prepare correctly
he called in resources they didn't need
cuomo
is now saying after being closed up
closed up closed up all to no avail
leads the country
almost is it in the top three for death
and death rate on coronavirus cuomo now
says
fellas we can't stay closed we
simply cannot stay closed until the
vaccine hits
critical mass the cost is too high
we will have nothing left to open
we must reopen the economy but we must
do it smartly and safely
did president trump write cuomo's speech
there did
did a daily wire writer write cuomo's
state of the state
what have we been saying now for months
and months and months we've said you
have to reopen if you don't reopen
soon there's not going to be anything to
reopen many
it kills me i'm a new yorker myself born
and raised
many of the great establishments of new
york are not going to reopen i think
it's some
it's expected that the majority of
restaurants in new york
are not going to reopen very sad what
he's done
to a generally speaking beautiful and
vibrant city
and now cuomo says now we got to reopen
yeah because your policy didn't work
because your lockdown policy didn't work
because your vaccine rollout certainly
didn't work it was a complete disaster
it andrew cuomo because of his stupid
policies not only got
grandma killed you know not only got
thankfully not my grandmothers
but lots of people's grandmothers killed
in new york
but andrew cuomo is now wasting the
vaccine because he put policies into
effect
that said that if healthcare workers did
not follow his guidelines
for exactly who to give the vaccine to
they could be fined they could face very
steep punishments
so do you know what was happening
healthcare workers were throwing out the
vaccine
because they didn't want to face the
state government penalties
finally now cuomo is lifting that
extremely
idiotic regulation too but but while
everyone's focusing on that part of the
state of the state i actually want to
focus in
on another statement which i think did
not get the kind of coverage it should
but it tells you exactly what the left
is after with these onerous and
draconian lockdown policies
today i'm speaking in person with a
small group
but broadcasting zooming and streaming
and in this new and different world the
audience is actually
larger not smaller technology and
technology-based relationships
work from home these are new realities
that will have dramatic consequences
this next year we will see economies
realign and reset
around the world we see the risk in the
peril but we also see the promise and
the potential
the question to be answered is what will
we make of this moment
is it positive or is it negative do we
move forward or do we move
backward is america is new york
stronger or weaker in the post-covered
world
those my friends are the questions that
we alone will answer in 2021 because the
future is in our
hands america and new york will be
stronger in the postcovid world if we
run these lunatic sociopath politicians
out on a railway line
and they will be weaker in the postcovid
world
if we follow what these people want to
do
the left does not want to go back to
normal
the left wants this to be the new normal
andrew cuomo just stated it explicitly
he said look usually we have an audience
usually i'm accountable to people in the
audience usually i have to answer
questions from people who are live
but now they're all on zoom isn't that
so much better i'm reaching more people
first of all i don't really see how
that's the case you could easily have a
zoom camera going
while having people in the room you're
just giving people more opportunities
and not everybody uses zoom i assure you
my grandmother
does not get on zoom every single day
does not know what zoom is my
grandmother in new york doesn't doesn't
use a computer
and i think that's true for a lot of
people so no i don't think it's
it's uh the way forward is to limit
spaces
that people get to interact with their
politicians no
what about working from home he says
this is the new reality you're all going
to start working from home
say business is a lot of money on office
space you just work work work
it worked very well i read one study
that said that people are working
more actually you think that when people
work from home they would work less
actually productivity
has increased in many places
that's the new reality is it you know
there's a
theory going on speaking of all these
sort of gnostic theories going around
the internet
they say that covet is the great reset
and this is supposed to be some grand
conspiracy theory it's not a grain
conspiracy theory the guy's talking
about it right there
he says we're going to reset but it's
going to be a re the economies are going
to realign they're going to reset
based on what happened with kovid we're
going to have new norms for society and
that's it
we're not going to gather as often as we
want to we're going to be on
zoom we're going to be wearing masks
certainly when we travel we're going to
be wearing masks a whole lot more not
going to see people smiling faces
we're going to muzzle ourselves out in
public
we're going to work from home much more
not going to go in and see people at the
office
not going to go have human interaction
just lock ourselves away in our rooms
and zoom all day long does that sound
like a fulfilling life
does that sound like the kind of society
you want to live in
not me not me this actually relates to
another
kind of on one hand silly story that's
going around
but people are missing the real meat of
the story
kamala harris is on the cover of vogue
kamala harris not even yet the
vice president she's the vice
president-elect she's on the cover and
it's
it's not a flattering picture and
apparently the left is very upset about
this because
she's wearing some kind of rumpled
pantsuit and
converse sneakers and it's just it isn't
framed very well i understand why the
kamala harris team
would be upset about this the
conservatives should be upset about this
because we have an
actual international model for a first
lady
and she's never been on the cover of any
of these magazines and we've got
extraordinarily impressive women
that have appeared throughout the trump
administration our current press
secretary kelly mcenany
would be the second choice you know if
melania trump who is
just very very beautiful
and an actual model if she can't be on
the cover i don't know how about like
kaylee how about kellyanne how about how
about all these very
impressive women who have been in the
trump administration
no they're not they're not going to be
on you're only going to put democrats on
okay that's fine
but then you look at what it says on the
cover
the cover it says madam vice president
kamala harris
and then in small print at the bottom
end the new america
i don't really care about the picture of
kamala harris i care about those words
those four words and the new america
what if you like the old america what
what is the new america
can you describe to me what that is it's
different right
this is something that we've seen from
the left now for years and years when
barack obama said
that he's going to fundamentally
transform the country
well if you're going to fundamentally
transform it that means it's going to be
completely different than it was
before right it's going to be different
not just
in degree it's going to be different in
kind you're going to fund essentially
change
the country
why because you don't like the country
if you like the country you don't want
to fundamentally
transform it if you love your wife you
don't want to fundamentally transform
your wife
so what is this new america that we're
talking about
we saw a little bit of it yesterday
remember joe biden came out and he said
we're going to build back businesses
we're going to build back businesses by
prioritizing black latino and women
businesses
what does that mean that means white
guys they're not going to get any help
they're going to be at a legal
disadvantage
we're going to we're going to build back
better by instituting a racial caste
system in america equality and and
biden says it's in the name of equality
that's the new america the the
president-elect is saying it
the vice president-elect has that
moniker on the cover of magazines expect
a lot more of this
expect to be gas-lit there was a
headline in the washington post
that i is very embarrassing for the
washington post
and it it should worry everybody
in this country because not even because
of the political issue it's talking
about
but because of the way that language is
being manipulated
you make these subtle changes in
language then you change
thought and then you change culture
fundamentally
which is why here at daily wire we're
trying to make culture we're trying to
push back
against that you know we've got a
backstage coming up thursday 7 p.m
eastern
even before that the actions of big tech
last week make it abundantly clear
that they will do everything they can to
silence opposing voices
they are completely out of control many
of you
have reached out to us to ask what you
can do to help
we've told you about our ambitious plans
this year with investigative
news entertainment content we're gonna
get some of that entertainment content
very soon
but with the actions of big tech last
week we we
cannot just stop there we have to take
action
to build or buy technology to protect
ourselves
from the attack that is coming so that
we can continue to deliver new content
to you
and fight back it is coming we are
seeing it coming down the bike it's
already happened to other guys in the
space
we're exploring all of the possibilities
new data centers payment gateways a lot
more
our team has been working very hard on
this we can't do
all of that with our current budget
simple as that we need
more of your support we are very
grateful to everyone who's become a
member already
uh this is going to ramp up this kind of
censorship is going to ramp up very very
quickly
biden is not even in office yet and it's
already happening
so we we really appreciate it head on
over become a member of the daily wire
we'll be right back with a lot more
joe biden has ambitious plans
or at least the people around him have
ambitious plans
joe biden probably doesn't know what day
it is or or what he had for breakfast
uh but the people around him his
administration has ambitious plans this
according to the washington post
which had a headline so
it was so offensive uh
but it's we're going to get so much more
of this it says quote
biden's ambitious lgbt agenda
poises him to be nation's most
pro-equality
president in history
you know if i had to think who are the
nation's most pro-equality presidents i
think
i mean joe biden he's going to like make
some bakers bake
cakes for gay weddings or something
right he's going to he's going to make
uh some baker they always keep targeting
these bakers
jack phillips in the in i think he's in
colorado
there are other bakers though that have
been targeted by activist groups
in the case of jack phillips there are
actually plenty of bakers
bakeries all around but these these
left-wing activists to go specifically
to his because they know he's christian
and say you've got to make a cake they
wanted him to make one cake once that
had all this kind of
uh heretical and blasphemous symbolism
on it it was
involved gender ideology and all this
kind of stuff but sure okay joe biden
he's gonna he's gonna make those guys
bake the cakes fine
does that make him more pro-equality
than say
abraham lincoln joe biden
makes some bakers bake cakes for
religious ceremonies that violate their
religious views okay that's one type of
equality
another type is freeing the slaves
who do who do you think is the most
pro-equality president
in history it is amazing how they did it
it was a one very left-wing lgbt group
called the human rights campaign
that appropriated for the gay rights
movement
the equality symbol so now when we talk
about equality i thought you talk about
racial equality you can talk about
equality
of the sexes you know men and women you
can talk about equality
spiritual equality before god no now the
word equality itself
is beholden to this very niche
interest group that is focusing on this
very niche
sort of question of sexual desire and
sexual ideology
that's where equality is now
now of course it won't remain there for
long because the minute that the left
believes
they can advance their agenda by
through racial grievance rather than
sexual grievance you know they're going
to ditch
the lgbt group then they're going to
move on to the racial question
or they're going to move on to some
other question but it's just so
offensive the washington post i think
used to be sort of a real newspaper
maybe i don't know
maybe not maybe maybe it wasn't maybe it
was always just this rag but
what a ridiculous headline biden's
ambitious lgbt agenda
poises him to be the nation's most
pro-equality president in history
by the way i mean equality word aside
the argument here
i think the premise is that that donald
trump was
anti-lgbt donald trump appointed the
first
openly gay acting cabinet member in
american history right rick rinnell
donald trump waved a gay pride flag so
even even if you're gonna make the
argument that
you know conservatives are really
anti-lgbt and biden's really
uh donald trump sure isn't right donald
trump
but they're gonna erase that i mean you
you saw headlines
after biden said he would appoint pete
butterjudge to run the trains or
whatever
he said historic pete buttige first
openly gay cabinet member is
as if rick grinnell didn't even exist
this is a total perversion of language
it's a total perversion of the way that
we communicate
and it results in censorship
so this is this is what political
correctness or whatever kind of you know
whatever words you want to use whatever
term you want to use
for these speech codes they try to force
you to say certain things
use certain words don't use other words
then when you don't go along with it
they censor you
they've been censoring a ton of
conservatives they've been this is
through big technology of course
up to and including the president of the
united states
and now they're when they say go build
your own twitter
then dan bongino goes and builds his own
twitter and they kill that twitter they
kill it from the google play store they
kill it from the apple app store then
when you can only look at it on a
browser they kill it
from the web services amazon web
services
devin nunes goes on television and he
says
republicans are being cut off from their
ways to communicate
a what was likely parlor is likely a
billion dollar company poof
it's gone but it's more than just the
financial aspect of that
republicans have no way to communicate
republicans have no way to communicate
that was devin nunes's claim and the
left made fun of him
they were laughing they said oh my devin
you have no way to communicate you're on
fox news right now
you're talking to millions of people you
liar you
idiot you're communicating i don't think
that's
exactly what he meant i don't want to
speak for devin nunes but it seems to me
what he's saying
is obviously we can communicate they
haven't put tape over all of our mouths
right we can still pick up the telephone
and call people
we can still write letters to one
another we can still write emails for
now
we can even still go on fox news how
many people is he going to talk to on
fox news
the biggest audience fox news has is
what 4 million between 3 and 4 million
it's a country of 320 some odd million
fox is a giant network
it's not that big it's not as big as
nbc plus abc plus cbs
plus the new york times plus the
washington post
plus cnn plus msnbc plus
npr plus pbs plus
plus plus plus plus
not nearly as big as that and moreover
to nunes's point
while conservatives are permitted i'm
still on twitter
i've seen tens of thousands of my
followers removed
and we'll get into why that is because i
was speculating on this yesterday
and in contra in contradiction of what
twitter was saying
and it would appear that my speculation
was closer to the truth but we'll get to
that in a second
sure i'm still on twitter some of the
other tech platforms haven't been too
tough
on us been very tough on trump but not
too tough on us
so we can still communicate to a degree
but we can only communicate
with the permission of the leftist
sensors
in medieval europe if you wanted to
publish something
you needed to receive the imprimatur of
the catholic church
there were censors right as as i've been
pointing out on this show i think
conservatives are a little misguided
to always just be talking about how
censorship's always bad and free speech
is good as though that's a real
dichotomy
when in fact all free speech regimes
involve some degree of censorship
because we have standards
and this has always been true even in
the united states even in the
most hardcore defenders of free speech
have
insisted on some boundaries but in in
medieval europe
renaissance europe there was you needed
to receive the imprimatur of the
catholic church
today you need to receive the imprimatur
of hipster rasputin
and his buddies in silicon valley you
need to receive the impromptu
of a very small and powerful liberal
i wouldn't even say radical ruling elite
if you want to reach a large audience
and there sure there are some groups i
mean this guy the tommy vitor
who is he's like the ringo of the
liberal pod bros he's on that show
pod save america tommy vitor said quote
don't miss my comments on how
conservative voices are being silenced
on fox news newsmax oan rush limbaugh
breitbart the federalist the washington
examiner
fox business sinclair the daily caller
red state the daily wire national review
the american spectator town hall haha
get it
because conservatives have all of these
outlets
billionaire radicals censored the duly
elected sitting president of the united
states
tommy vitor and these other liberal
people
can giggle all they want and say no look
the daily wire is still permitted to
exist for now
well come on what are you complaining
about censorship
yeah you've given us some crumbs in the
ability to communicate
but then whenever there's any sort of
threat to your power
anything that just irritates you a
little bit in the liberal
regime you nuke it you're going to kick
a ton of people
including the president off of parlor
for various reasons perhaps reasons
we'll get into or off of
twitter rather reasons we'll get into in
a second
okay they're going to go over to parlor
no they're not because you're not going
to let them
the president of the united states all
of these are such
bad faith arguments from guys like the
pod bro i only i expect that from the
pod bros those guys
it's hard for them to string a coherent
sentence together
much much less make a persuasive and
serious argument
but i don't want to hear about national
review
and the federalist and fox business
if if these oligarchs
can censor the president
then there there is really no limit to
the censorship regime
and the rest of us are just around
because they haven't gotten around to us
yet or maybe maybe they don't feel they
they quite need to in a way that they do
need to go out and take out the
president because he's a real threat to
them
i was i was pleased to see i'm never
pleased to see anything out of germany
you know as
norm mcdonald famously said i don't know
if you guys are history buffs but
that country germany really scares me
they've they've done some things in
history
uh i'm i'm rarely i mean i germany has
contributed in other ways to the world
but angela merkel really is not their
leader and she always she hates trump
and
she's not a great leader but even she
came out and admitted that this twitter
ban
on the president of the united states is
quote
problematic obviously the spokespeople
choosing choosing their words carefully
but said that
the permanent ban is really a big deal
and it it potentially undermines the
quote fundamental right
to freedom of speech alexi navalny
alexei navalny
is the opposition leader in russia
he is the the most prominent critic of
vladimir putin and has been for
a very long time now at least a decade
and i
i don't think he's any great fan of
donald trump
but alexi navalny came out he said quote
i think that the ban on donald trump of
donald trump on twitter
is an unacceptable act of censorship
the election is a straightforward and
competitive process you can participate
in it
you can appeal the results they're being
monitored by millions of people
the ban on twitter is a decision of
people we don't know
in accordance with a procedure we don't
know this is a great argument
much more precise than and
thorough than angela merkel saying it's
problematic so both of them
are are on the right side of this
question
navalny is going out there and defending
the american election
he's then defending donald trump's right
to appeal
the results of that election in court
which obviously the trump campaign did
then he's saying you know
maybe it's an imperfect process whatever
but you know it is being looked at by
lots and lots of people
and so whatever you think about the
elections there's
something there you can kind of rely on
compared to
twitter's decision which was made by a
handful of people
we don't know anything about their
decision they don't need to tell us the
truth
we we don't have any oversight no
democratic accountability whatsoever
that is very worrisome and alexi navalny
came out and said
that the idea that trump violated the
terms of service of twitter
sounds like bs and it does there's a
good article on the daily wire right now
about how that that excuse doesn't seem
to to hold up in light of the evidence
now there's a separate issue which is
conservatives have been seeing
their followers drop a lot i think i've
lost it over 30
000 followers at this point some people
have lost more ben's lost like 100 000
or more but it's all conservatives
if you if you look at the preliminary
analyses of this
the conservatives are the ones who are
losing and prominent liberal accounts
are the ones who are gaining followers
so twitter yesterday they came out and
they said
the reason you're losing followers this
is just routine maintenance go in we
want to make sure it's not bots we want
to go in and make sure it's real people
who are actively using these accounts
so no big deal i pointed out that this
seemed to strain credulity
because if if twitter if twitter's
excuse were correct then it would seem
they would go in and take out all of the
accounts right i don't
again as lexi navalny says we don't know
the exact details of this process but if
they're saying there are a lot of
accounts it's routine
and we just take them out of the
follower accounts until they confirm it
then the way that the numbers would have
to move is all the accounts that they
removed from the follower accounts would
disappear all at once
right as as twitter did it and then as
people
presumably some people are going to
confirm their accounts then the numbers
would increase
but actually the way it worked was they
were all decreasing
twitter today seemed to change the story
then they came out and they said
the reason conservatives are losing tens
of thousands of followers
is that they've removed 70 000 accounts
that had promoted the q
anon conspiracy theory
in recent days and they're they're
cracking down on this kind of content
and because of
q anon which is this conspiracy theory
they were going to take away all of
those accounts so that's that's a little
different then
this is routine maintenance you know
this happens all the time we just want
to make sure people are using these
accounts
now they're coming and saying no it's
we're targeting this one specific thing
that's called q anon again just
buttressing navalny's point
that these decisions are being made
behind closed doors we can't really
check
on any of it and these are the people
who now have the ability
to censor the sitting president of
the united states
so q anon is being kicked off of twitter
70 000 accounts gone quote these
accounts were engaged in sharing harmful
q anon associated content
at scale and were primarily dedicated to
the propagation of this conspiracy
theory across the service
what is q anon q and i don't really know
much about it i haven't looked really
too far into it
but as far as i can tell the edges of it
are that there's a global pedophile ring
of elite people that
uh involve you know royalty and heads of
state and billionaires and business
leaders and they're
they're involved in sex trafficking and
we got to stop them you know
and uh when people i i don't really know
any of the other details but that's at
least the kind of description i've read
when people ask how could anyone fall
for that crazy theory
you you do have to remind them that uh
jeffrey epstein happened
you know and uh or photos of him with
like prince andrew and
multiple u.s presidents and bill clinton
flew on his plane a lot of times and so
i'm i'm mostly blaming liberal elites
for the spread of these kinds of
theories
and now i don't i don't know exactly how
the q
anon thing relates to the jeffrey
epstein thing i assume they're related
right
it seems like too much of a coincidence
for it not to be but in any case fine
it's twitter's prerogative they want to
get rid of people who are spreading this
theory about
the q person fine fine how about blm
how about blm because twitter's argument
seems to me goes like this q anon is a
dangerous conspiracy theory
and in part it helped motivate people
who went to capitol hill and rioted
and therefore it's our right and
responsibility to take it off of our
platform
okay what about the blm conspiracy
theory what about the conspiracy theory
being spread by very prominent people
lebron james famously said black men
can't walk out of
out of their doors in this country
without being hunted down
many many prominent democrats elected
democrats have said
that there is an epidemic in this
country of racist cops
hunting down and slaughtering innocent
black men
for no reason and that is not true there
is no evidence of that whatsoever
we've gone through on this show ad
nauseam the actual numbers on
officer involved killings black men
with with regard to many of the the data
points here location
race of the cops relation to other
officer involved incidents
just the total number right it
it doesn't it doesn't hold true
but that's the that's the premise of blm
and blm did inspire a lot of people
to go not just on one day to a
government building
but on many days for weeks and months to
many government buildings
and torch courthouses and torch police
stations and
torch businesses and loot and kill
people
dozens of people with the encouragement
to go out there and protest and don't
stop and we won't stop
of elected people including kamala
harris and don't
don't you tell me that she was only
encouraging the peaceful people
because kamala harris raised money to
bail them out of jail
the people who were arrested now now
what their promise what they're going to
say is
well no but they were arrested unjustly
because
because blm good and whatever right wing
thing there is
bad did twitter kick off blm
no they didn't it's obviously they
didn't kick off kamala harris
and they didn't kick off the blm account
and you know what twitter did they
changed their bio
the actual bio on twitter said hashtag
black lives matter they associated
themselves with the movement
those are just the standards that we're
living under now
and we can complain about it we can
point out the hypocrisy they don't care
about the hypocrisy
to them they'll read about the q anon
thing and they'll say this is completely
crazy
fair enough i'm sure it is really kooky
i just haven't haven't gone too far into
it
but they won't even acknowledge the
jeffrey epstein thing was kind of weird
wasn't it did he really
he just happened to be permitted to kill
himself in prison and all this
got off the hook and then alex acosta
the us attorney said he belonged to
intelligence and his
associate her family's got connections
to for international intelligence
it's just a little weird isn't it no
can't acknowledge that
however we will believe a far more
ridiculous
conspiracy theory than anything about
jeffrey epstein
or uh his private island or whatever
they'll believe that there's an epidemic
in this country of
uh racist cops slaughtering innocent
black men
they don't need to present evidence for
that that will be not only tolerated but
promoted by the censors
and anything else from the kookiest
conspiracy theories
all the way to just like pointing out
something about jeffrey epstein
that will come under suspicion
bernie sanders is now following
the logic of this censorship he says
quote
let's be clear if trump is too dangerous
to send out a tweet or a facebook post
he's too dangerous to be
commander-in-chief donald trump must be
removed from office immediately
and held accountable for his horrific
acts of sedition
violence and chaos he has not committed
an act of sedition
he has not committed an act of violence
i suppose he has committed acts of chaos
that's kind of why he was elected was to
mix up the system
but the system doesn't like getting
mixed up listen to the logic though
billionaire oligarch radicals censor the
duly elected sitting president
millionaire radical leftist in the
senate
takes this action as evidence
that trump is if he's too dangerous to
be on twitter
is therefore too dangerous to be
president he must be removed from office
immediately
so if you follow that trail of logic the
reason he must be removed
from office immediately is because the
billionaire radicals say so
do you see how quickly this moves
we got a sense room we got to kick him
off social media says the oligarch
well if he can't be on social media he
can't be president says the senator
now they try to remove him we're going
to impeach the president says
the speaker of the house and republicans
probably i hope they don't roll over on
impeachment but they'll they'll probably
roll over on something like censure or
something like that this is the way the
regime
works the liberal regime it all works in
accord
the media and technology and the
bureaucracy
and the elected people it all and higher
education it all
works together when are we
going to push back through all legal
channels
grow a spine and go up against the
system i'm michael knowles this michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 today check
out the ben shapiro show where we'll be
talking
about the fbi's concerns about the
possibility of new riots and attacks
democrats pushing toward a second
impeachment and democrats saying they're
all for unity
but they have just a few conditions
check out the show that's today on the
bench bureau show